Ma cosa diavolo è questo ma è uno
scherzo Spero Scusa ci deve essere stato
un errore io ho ordinato un vestito da
donna taglia S ma quello che mi è
arrivato è un vestito per le bambole
sarebbe possibile ricevere il vestito
giusto nessun errore nella descrizione
dell'abito ci sono scritte le dimensioni
la taglia S si riferisce a un S per le
bambole Ma non è vero non c'era
assolutamente scritto nulla nella Des
Ops mi sa che hai ragione E ora cosa
devo fare da Sei una nipotina hai già il
suo regalo di Natale non ho nipoti non
me ne faccio nulla di un vestito per le
bambole in questo caso ti conviene fare
il reso Buona giornata m fai il reso
Grazie È sempre complicatissimo fare i
Resi vediamo Come si fa il reso sul sito
di impost ma è semplicissimo
adoro amo te lo giuro un vestito per le
bambole Ma io basita il problema adesso
è trovare un vestito per quella
Benedetta festa come non ci andiamo più
Paolo il tuo ex con Chiara e Quando
pensavi di dirmelo Sai cosa ti dico amo
che noi il vestito per le feste ce
l'abbiamo già il pigiama film cibo e
gossip a casa mia